to get people involved to get people to
sign a recall petition it's a challenge
and and it's tough it requires a lot of
time a lot of energy and a lot of work
and and i think just because of that we
weren't able to get to the point we
needed to get to but we all should be
proud of the hard work we put into it in
addition to that i do believe that
fighting against george gascon for the
last 20 months has really made him
change some of his policies and brought
to light all the bad and horrible things
he was doing and so he tries to cover
everything up but i think
us fighting has really got a lot of
media involved and a lot of people have
seen
of the rogue and radical policies of
george gascon and i think he's made some
changes
as a result of that this wasn't a
political power grab at all
i'm a democrat there are many democrats
here in los angeles who have been
standing up to george gascon we believe
in doing the right thing we believe in
following the law we believe in making
sure the public is safe we want reforms
but we shouldn't sacrifice public safety
to do that that has nothing to do with
politics being a good prosecutor has
absolutely nothing to do with politics
all these individuals hundreds of
thousands of them came out wanted george
gascon removed from office and feel like
he isn't doing the job he's supposed to
be doing
why doesn't he respond to that at least
have something to say about it
you know why because he doesn't care but
i do have a message for george i'm not
going anywhere i'll be back at work
tomorrow i'm going to keep fighting
against your policies and directives i'm
gonna make sure that everybody sees all
the things that you are doing i'm gonna
keep keep standing up for victims and
survivors i'm gonna keep fighting for
the children and my cases i'm not going
anywhere and so my message to you is
your days are numbered 2024 is coming up
sooner than you think and we are going
to get you out of office
[Music]
you